Reggie Aloysius Miller the third on the
call for Spurs rockets game for Sunday
at 9:00 Eastern on TNT first of all what
do you have on here with the sneaker
game well I know you guys been talking a
lot about mr. ball big ballers the big
ballers and $500 and these were my
closet in a box and if I am going to pay
an exorbitant amount of money for shoes
yeah this is going to be only one brand
I'm going to pay that amount of money
for I don't know what these are
Pauly do we know what kind of Jordans
these are I'm confirming in the box and
I was so and they'll go back in the box
how many shoes do you have I'm going to
sneak your head so I don't know you're
not no I'm not
dan Air Jordan to nicknamed the Italian
stallion 1987 is what richest we're a
good year for Jordan good Rick a good
year but these would be worth well
they're more than 500 oz because they're
1981 a 7 don't be waiting after the
silver party I don't we go away and
argue on I got to secure you with me you
outside secure you your security get out
of here come on Q but your shoe sponsor
was spot built my first two years
okay we're spot built or they do you
even have in talkity talkity talkity in
lot build you have those shoes I do not
have those shoes I have the poster of me
looking like I was 13 years old holding
a carton of milk we're in my spot bills
like but no and then after that I was
fortunate and lucky for the rest of my
career to be with thankee and go against
this man but it was it is it is it
difficult to put on Air Jordans um it
was very difficult to wear them and play
against them wait did you wear Jordans
when you've nod not when he was at his
height no cuz the only one who could
wear Jordan was Michael George okay I
started wearing him once he started that
in a buck 65 careful here we go here we
go when I started like I can take shots
because I took a lot of time
I feel I should have a license to take
shot that there's a falling who's on the
phone in the Carolina number on hold no
I do
Wow no I well you started early oh
that's not dirty get me out of here few
security cubes got this three-on-three
League I asked you about that I love the
country good to be in that
three-on-three what I want to be
remembered with my dignity well okay I
still have dignity but the way I went
out that's how I want people to remember
me but it's a great concept I love it I
was talking to his people in the back
but I tell you what you better have some
er technicians on on hand because
there's gonna be a lot of guys that are
gonna look this your heart will tell you
you can play your head your head
possibly these joints right here and
right here you play right now
I certainly casued I certainly yeah but
but if you were let's say you were
scrimmaging let's say you're doing Spurs
Rockets and there was a scrimmage going
on yeah you could run I could run and
you hold your own I don't know if I
would hold my own but I could definitely
I would embarrass myself okay yeah I
wouldn't dance myself but if quiet
Leonard's on you oh I would need
practice if Kawhi Leonard was on me
right now obviously but you'd score on
it no you would not score on Leonard
score on Kawhi right now one-on-one no
with with those shoes on oh hey hold on
yeah look I don't know if I could score
one-on-one if we were to play one-on-one
with Kawhi or Patrick Beverley two guys
I think are great one-on-one defenders
right now at 51 now what's the list on
there
Moochie Norris Mookie horse you could
score oh well who else is on there Mike
James what's going on him [ __ ] yeah good
Kwame Brown okay who else Rashad me
cans bucket Reggie Evans will get hurt
you cannot be out here could harden
stomp you right now I have a hard time
stopping him well no that's not the
point
I've had a hard time stopping him but
that was never the point of your game
could James Harden lonna 31 yeah
could he lock you down at 51 yes he
probably could cuz I don't want to hear
it I am 5-1 now could I feel like I
could shoot and play a horse and around
the world with these dudes any now I
wanted a one-on-one
Russell Westbrook jr. the thirds gonna
have you locked up we yeah that's not
good yeah but I will have something for
Russell Westbrook the third you will
yeah you kids go on Steph Curry right
now know what I think I could score own
stuff maybe you could if I got ten shots
you give me about ten times against
Steph Curry no way right now
no no because now by your third attempt
you're going to be time you're going to
be tired and you have already gone to
your best to remove anaphoras are you
gonna do that what are you going to do
we had a bet here the other day we were
talking about great Celtics of all time
and we were talking about Larry legend
so Paulie thinks if I had Larry Bird on
I said who's the best Celtic of all time
Larry's going to say Larry and I say
he'll say Bill Russell who do you think
Larry says Bill Russell yeah yep oh they
the cavea cuz Larry's made you some fake
humility because he thinks he's the
greatest Celtic of all time we all think
we're better than we technically I don't
think Larry would utter another name he
begged well there's a lot of guys a lot
of guys he'd do that song and Danny I
think if you are a Celtic it's almost
ingrained in you to kind of revert back
to Bill Russell to me Bill Russell is
one of the games it's hard just it's
hard not to say Bill Russell yeah even
though Bird is cocky I think he would
say believe it was sacrilegious yeah
yeah to say Bert you've got the Spurs
Rockets game for Sunday 9:00 Eastern on
TNT change of events in
that series yeah I'm sure Rita Tony
Parker yeah but the Spurs came up with a
big win is this the last call for the
Spurs
well okay we keep saying that every year
yeah don't we and then nobody hugger
done Ginobili looks 39 LaMarcus Aldridge
doesn't look like an all-star but you
still have a young Clinard and you still
have Gregg Popovich but is that enough
in this series I was wonderful in this
series look that there's still a lot of
games to be left I want to see what the
adjustments going to be without Tony
Parker I don't know if you start Patty
Mills you know do you start Manu
Ginobili because now you're affecting
chemistry coming off your bench you've
got a rookie in the Jonte Murray from
from Washington do you go big and start
Simmons or Kyle Anderson from UCLA so
these are decisions popping his staff is
going to make certainly losing a veteran
player like Tony Parker it's going to
affect the team because he played well
in that first round
you know matchup versus the Grizzlies
they play well in Game one but had 18
points before that injury you see a
hall-of-famer do absolutely first about
him and Manu or again I remember people
get all caught up that the Hall of Fame
is just your NBA career you got to take
into account your international and for
us American players your college to me
that's why I think Vince Carter is a
Hall of Famer as well remember he went
to two Final Fours I believe it was at
North Carolina plus and out what 1920
once play two more years so 21 years
service to the Association he'll be in
the Hall of Fame feels like he's had a
couple of careers though Vince Carter
when you there was a college right then
he came in as an agriculture yeah yeah
of course the long list of next Michael
Jordan night and then came back as a
three-point specialist who can still
dunk at age 40 well is the question is
he a Hall of Fame player or is he a
first-ballot Hall of Famers that's what
everyone gets caught up in because
people are saying Tracy McGrady is a
Hall of Fame player should he have been
a first-ballot which he is all a Famer
I say absolutely yes I mean this guy
that led the league in scoring three
years but he's like what did he do in
the playoffs
yes that's what raises a lot of red
flags for people personally I think he's
a
first ballot hall-of-famer should we
have just NBA elephant yes we should
have just which they do or call it
Oliphant yeah just an NBA Hall of Fame
and just an International Hall of Fame
which I believe they do yeah but people
get caught up and thinking that when you
go into the Hall of Fame
it's just what you've done in the NBA
that's why Tony Parker Manu Ginobili
they both have what three or four rings
and their international play Argentina
as well as France they're always in the
Olympics and they're always competing
they'll never win the gold medal because
how is it American you know Ginobili is
going left every single time I know but
he still went left every single time you
know what he's going to do well it's
very deceptive because he takes one or
two dribbles right what's kind of lures
you in but yes I don't know easy though
I know I know I know just like you know
every single time James Harden is coming
off that high screen and roll he's going
to grab your arm bring you in get fouled
in shoot three it's unbelievable what's
going on in these playoffs with Harden
and Lou Williams and getting fouled from
beyond but you know it's happening where
are the officials calling and why do
best
why do better players get more calls
than the guys who aren't good players
there they have the basketball most of
the time yeah but we had this with their
bead phantom foul I'm sure there were
times you guarded somebody knew when I I
never found and then you almost get like
somebody found I would get the benefit
of doubt if I was going against a lesser
player yeah when I was guarding Joe
Dumars Michael Jordan and Clyde Drexler
I never got any call yeah they got every
single song okay all righty
you can't have this online we're here
he's Reggie Aloysius Miller will
continue with him coming up Ice Cube
will join us as well you and cuber cool
you I'm using insecurity get on it
q could I use a security Guardium with
my Jordan guanine could you score on
cube right now who I would mess around
and get a triple-double on q right
double cube barber in the bag I got
everybody
like a party in the green room back
there I'm having so much fun back there
we'll continue with Reggie Aloysius
Miller here 17 after the our damn
Packers go with what you've seen so far
in the playoffs give me a different
scenario than cabs warriors well I
really think Washington in Boston the
way that series is going and how
physical and the altercation yeah it's
going to be tough for either whoever
went to wins that series to be Cleveland
because like Cleveland's going to win
and for possibly a gentlemen 5-series
who has a better chance to beat in the
Cavalier between the Wizards in the
Celtics I would say the beat Cleveland
you've got to be physical and you've got
to have size and width Mohini coming
back and Gortat inside possibly
especially with those two guards bill in
wall I would say Washington I just don't
know if Isiah Thomas because he's been
fantastic to me
probably the second-best player in these
playoffs behind LeBron James and maybe
Kawhi Leonard is she and a player yeah
yeah because he can carry especially you
see the fourth quarter numbers that
alone lets you know that he's in a tight
player because a lot of guys can't do
that especially at five-nine five-ten be
able to carry your franchise and your
team where matters the most but are you
building around him if your boss you
need pieces you need more scoring he is
a great piece to build around but they
need more size they really do to compete
with with Cleveland can the rock okay
out of the Rockets Spurs who can beat
Golden State our best chance to beat
Golden State both can you think the
Spurs can not now or it's gonna be very
difficult with the loss of Tony Parker
yeah I still believe they can beat the
Rockets but the Rockets have so much
confidence right now and James Hart is
playing out of this world which he has
all year but his shooters have finally
found their target
Anderson struggled in that first round
matchup versus the Thunder they've got
the best bench scoring and Lou Williams
and here
and they just want to shoot threes make
layups and get to the free-throw line
which they do everyone's like you know
take away their threes well you take
away their threes they're not shooting
very many mid-range shots everything is
laying up yeah or they're getting fouled
and going to the free-throw line but is
it just the change in coaching
philosophy here with D'Antoni that made
this team and may James Harden different
look in adding the right pieces yeah I
mean to go out and trade for Ryan
Anderson and Aragorn who felt that they
were someone in jail in New Orleans to
make a midseason trade to Lou Williams
to add to that system and look to go to
James Harden before the season and said
look we're switching your positions
you've been a shooting guard your whole
career we're going to move you to point
guard and to lead the league in assists
it's been unbelievable or close to leave
believe me I know that you guys that
whenever you get around sometimes
there's trash talk that goes on I
thought it was interesting that Allen
Iverson and Tim Hardaway were back and
forth with each other on who had the
best crossover interesting yeah you
didn't know that they were chat how did
not okay if I said best crossover move
breaking ankles
is it Iverson and Hardaway those are the
two best there probably in my opinion
have the two best crossovers but
remember now whenever they change your
rule for you because they had to change
the crossover rule because AI carried
the ball so then they changed it which
now they're back to because now Isiah
Thomas is carrying the ball on his
crossover but if I had mine only call it
my gate it's not hairy
it happens really quick it happens quick
but you know it's gonna happen Mike
Iverson was blatant only he was out were
talking a poly pull up the pull-up the
Michael Jordan crossover because that's
what everyone's you know kind of reverse
back to and he's even talked about I
wanted to use my my my best move against
the best player ever that is a blatant
carry twice he crossed him quite and
Mike almost got that shot
nah you think you think you got it
he got it off in time it is really close
though when you see guys getting shots
off it looks like somebody just about
but on it as a shooter yeah you kind of
want that closeness because your
reaction time to getting enough it's
much better as opposed to you're there
and I'm shooting people expect us to
make it because we have so much room if
you're riding my grill the reaction time
is much better for me to get that shot
off and make it as opposed to me I'd
much rather have her someone close to me
than someone being two or three feet off
I not mock mullah Abdul Rauf had a great
query underrated very underrated yeah
and he was spectacular
income Jay had a pretty good one but you
know people don't he carried two Michael
did a lot of things that we good job
Teddy ha good what are these again Paul
you got your George what are these
they're Katie Stewart to Morton to Q
help a brother out a few security help a
brother out what punk ice cubes him back
he brought his own barber he's getting
freshened up right I told you okay so is
a party Johnny you can do such a great
time in the green room it is a party
back there she was getting a haircut
yeah his stuff tight animators he's a
big time a Lister movie sorry should be
and she puts you in anything no but
would you look to see we grew up with
NWA and IQ Ice Cube is one of those guys
that you know coming from California we
were like it was always dad you like
though when you first heard that because
that was always you weren't you weren't
you weren't supposed to write like bring
it home to mom but I was in college then
so it was great because I was away from
mom and you have an eight-track tape or
did you have the cassette tango that's
when you had the big boom-boom bong you
had a meteor to take and you would go
and you were just blare in waa and
obviously Ice Cube was you know the
forefront of that group but there was no
real wanting to have ice cubes voice and
his bravado and like he has the greatest
diss song of all time no Vaseline and to
this day that it's the greatest of all
time all right when you talk about
dissing and getting personal it is the
best song so to this day and before
games
it was either POC or ice cube that you
know you would listen to to get ready
because that's what was mine did you
meet to buck
yes well I did a movie with him in
pollinating the whatever was called uh
dot uh with Jim Belushi's look it up
someone but my gang-related cutting room
floor everybody was there and what's it
called game lady gang related
gang-related okay yeah it could Park
played on he talked a good girl Betty
talked a good game yeah he did sometimes
that's all you need why I'm sitting here
living proof I know you played a good
game you play great K but I always hate
the guy on the court who's losing who's
dribbling and then says he's got next
like you're going dude you don't have
necks you're losing but that guy's like
pounding the ball got I got next man I
don't know no that's not fair
it was unfair what if we just went us
six to a place I have a question okay
was in the back yeah and he has his
threat
what have we formed our own
three-on-three team hmm you think Cuba
lettuce in well we're the players yeah
y'all out of y'all whelming will it
McLovin yeah McLovin can shoot and give
you a mid-range jumper if you leave him
open Hillard a midriff mid-range to ask
you how cute you really want to apply
all you know no I do not you're not
again fantastic idea in concept can't
wait to watch but again this and this is
telling you you can yeah you can't
punish a body's the body er er 911
he's Reggie Aloysius Miller junior the
third Spurs rockets game for Sunday at
9:00 Eastern you're going to get your
stuff tight yeah watch you here I'm
gonna go get touched up and then you
know go from there
right but okay to ask you and he's got
his hat on he got it got a thing no
that's like doc you miss would he pay
$500 right now for levar ball big
ballers big baller shoes
500 I wouldn't put my damn kids my
I might have to anyway so you could
score on cue right I don't know he might
bring that self-control you know I got
it I got a little prison gaming this is
all my files a major 7 we're going to go
behind new kills like bring the guy
behind you waiting for you my god body
or magar bhai no we come out of like are
you hell where's you know that yeah bill
Sussman your place man Ice Cube joins us
next year the Dan Patrick show the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience